welcome to rational science
today we're going to be talking about
this lady her name is
sabine hassenfelder
she goes by sabine like they said here
in germany
and uh why did i select her well the
other day i was discussing this
gentleman juan matasena
and he's a strength theorist involved
primarily with
mathematical visions of how this
universe works
the phenomenologists like sabine here uh
what they do is
they want to see experiments and so
there seems to be a little bit of a
schism
in mathematical physics between people
who try to approve or confirm
the theories of mathematical physics and
the other people who say well it's
beyond hope you know you there's no way
you're gonna run
an experiment to prove um you know what
happens inside a black hole for example
and so they just want to do equations
and that's where the
clash comes in okay
okay uh this is who uh miss uh ms
i think she's married ms hassenfelder um
is she's a theoretical physicist she
works at the frankfurt institute for
advanced studies
uh that's a couple miles up here north
of where i live
and uh she's in the super fluid dark
matter group i think she leads it
uh she is into what is known as
phenomenological phenomenological
quantum gravity
and what is that well it's the
application of theoretical physics
to experimental data by making
quantitative
uh predictions based upon uh known
theories
okay so essentially what they want to do
is uh make some quantitative predictions
but the key issue with the
phenomenologists is that they want to
prove or confirm their hunches in the
lab their equations their predictions
they want to confirm those in the lab
with some kind of experiment okay
so let's see in a little more detail
what uh phenomenology is
uh this is from the wikipedia
phenomenological uh
quantum gravity is the research field
that deals with phenomenology
of quantum gravity the relevance of this
research area derives from the fact that
none
of the candidate theories for quantum
gravity has yielded experimentally
testable predictions and i think someone
in her group or maybe she herself
wrote that article or helped write that
article and these are the
the things that she's referring to
string theory loop quantum gravity
we talked about strength theory the
other day causal
dynamical triangulation asymptotically
safe gravity
and uh causal causal sets
okay these are the five uh
branches that have attempted to figure
out you know what gravity is
uh specifically trying to merge the
equations of quantum mechanics with
those
of general relativity in some way so
that they get this gut
this grand unified theory or toe the
theory of everything
that's their goal phenomenological
models are designed to bridge this gap
by allowing
physicists to test four general
properties that the hypothetical correct
theory of quantum gravity has
okay that's their goal that's what
they're up to
here's a you can say the second part of
that and where they
find some problems due to this current
lack of experiments it is not known for
sure that gravity is indeed quantum
uh that in other words that general
relativity can be quantized
and so evidence is required to determine
whether this is the case
phenomenological models are also
necessary to assess the promise
of future quantum gravity experiments
direct experiments for quantum gravity
would require
around 15 orders of magnitude higher
than can be achieved with current
particle accelerators
as well as needing a detector the size
of a large planet
as a result experimental investigation
of quantum gravity was long
thought to be impossible with current
levels of technology
however in the early 21st century new
experiment designs and
technologies have arisen which suggests
that
indirect approaches to testing quantum
gravity may be feasible over the next
few decades
so we're talking about something that
the strength here is say
well you know it's never going to happen
or if it's going to happen it's going to
happen way in the future meanwhile
we're going to do the math to see if we
can prove it mathematically
and that's okay we don't need the
experiment that's more or less their
their idea because they can't come up
with an experiment
some people are trying to see if there's
some kind of experiment they can run
for string theory but a lot of most of
them i would say have given up and they
just do math
and then you have these other people who
say look we're following the uh
the custom you could say
uh of not only doing math but we're
gonna
back it up with some experiment and
that's where there's this
schism going on in the church okay
some people are just doing pure math and
the other people say well
let's do an experiment to confirm
strength theory and there's not much to
confirm like you know
what is strength theory well it's a
vibration of a strain in the case of the
graviton which is the one that concerns
us here we're talking
about a closed loop string that is
vibrating one dimensional string that's
what they say okay
that's what they propose well how are
you going to prove it i mean what does
that change anything
we still have to we still have to show
how a graviton
attracts something else you know what
the mechanism is
and that's where these people say let's
go to the lab so
right now the these two groups are not
speaking to each other
and like sheldon glashow uh the person i
named the other day he's a nobel prize
winner and he's one of the first to
object to string theory he tried to
keep it away from hardware university
and they said no he was overruled
but he said you know it's not even
physics
anymore and he says who's going to work
on the accelerators that we built you
know we have the fermilab we have slack
stanford linear accelerator the the lac
and so on we have all these accelerators
out there
and who's going to use them if the new
generation for the last 50
years at least since the 1970s uh have
moved
into string theory
and they're abandoning quantum mechanics
because they believe that
it's like there's no nothing more to do
in math
in uh quantum mechanics or like um
niels bohr said uh quantum mechanics
is a complete theory einstein said no it
ain't
and right now these people are thinking
that einstein was really right because
it's not complete in the sense it
doesn't incorporate uh gravitons the
gravity
you know where's gravity in quantum
mechanics for the small world for the
micro world
they can't include it in there and so
the strength ears have gone out there
and taken
the graviton and trying to merge it with
black holes to see if they can figure
out something along those
lines as we showed the other day and
other people like uh sabine rosenfelder
what she does is
well she says uh maybe we can uh
discover something around the black hole
here on earth
and with the technology that we have
available to us she has hope
in that sense okay in fact here's a
summary of how she thinks
okay i can get this thing here
give me a second
this is what she says uh she says i
wrote a paper on it uh what quantum
gravity needs
is more experiments okay you see where
she's coming from
uh with this math won't solve quantum
gravity experimentation
will okay and she starts uh by saying
you know how
how she got started in physics he said i
was awed by the power of mathematics to
describe the natural world
so it's not like she's shunning uh
mathematics
it's like she says yeah it's great
mathematics is great you need
mathematics
uh but then she continues practitioners
of these research programs were
convinced
they would decipher nature using nothing
but the power of mathematics
and she continues and uh i think in a
separate paper she said for context
i have worked on this for many years
myself and i came to the conclusion
that there are multiple mathematically
consistent solutions to the problem
only experiment will eventually tell us
which one is right
is is the right one but there won't be
any experiments
okay and part of that she as he's
referring in part
to the string theorists which have
abandoned experiments essentially
because they can't come up with an
experiment that will
show that their theory or their
proposals are correct
uh the other hand she has hope but i
don't know if they can come up with an
experiment that they can imagine where
they can
prove the existence of the graviton or
how it works or whatever
okay so right now they're kind of like
an impasse and a new generations i think
are moving
more into string theory because the math
there has not finished whereas the math
in quantum mechanics apparently it seems
to be over
so there are some kind of a crisis i
think yeah that's the way i see it
maybe i'm wrong right okay well the
problem is here
for the last ten thousand years the rest
of the world has proposed discrete
particles that's essentially what they
use
what do we propose instead we're saying
that all atoms in the universe are
physically interconnected so we're
proposing
a totally different universe than what
these people have
been doing for the last 400 years okay
so uh
let's see some of the differences here
uh miss sabine
is probably uh in favor of quantum
mechanics obviously i think you know i
think
i don't have to mention that and so what
does she propose she proposes that light
is maybe a stream of
particles photons okay or maybe she
thinks of it as a 2d
pair of 2d transverse waves uh that are
perpendicular to each other they run
orthogonally
okay this is her vision of this
she's probably very likely i don't want
to put words in her mouth but she
probably also accepts this
that this is the atom and she will
probably deny it and say no that's not
my atom but you say okay what is
electricity
what is current and she would probably
say well it's the flow of electron beads
from atom to atom you know they go from
valence band to valence band
and so we have to go back to the atom
and ask her okay what atom did you use
to use your to do electricity to do
current
and she's she's had no other choice but
to go with the planetary atom that mr
bohr and rutherford came up with in
other words with the orbiting bead
and now they can put that beat anywhere
they want it doesn't matter the point is
why doesn't that bead
fly away spontaneously why is it stuck
to the nucleus what is the yellow stuff
that keeps it
bound to the nucleus that's what they
have to answer
and if they can't answer that question
they can't say that uh electricity is
the flow of
electron beams and i don't care about
mother nature's adam here i care about
their
what is their atom the one they're going
to do their electricity with they can't
bring that atom the planetary model say
okay this is electricity
and then you say is that your oh no
that's not my atom this is what this is
the way they handle these things
this is where the problem is okay uh
what do we propose instead well we
propose something new
and that is that all atoms are
physically interconnected
they're interconnected but what you see
on the upper right there
light is a torsion along a rope
there all atoms are connected by a
rope-like
dna-like mediator
and the mechanism is that as the atoms
expand and contract
they torque the rope light is torsioned
along a physical rope
torsion is the fastest thing imaginable
it explains why light is so fast
okay and one at the bottom right you'll
see the construction of the atom
the rope is made of two threads one of
the threads goes through the center of
the atom builds the proton star
and all the atoms in the universe
contribute one thread to the proton star
all the other atom in the universe they
contribute another um
thread and that one coils around and
forms the electron shell a membrane
that encapsulates the star and there you
see the model we're saying that when the
atoms expand and contract they torque
the rope
that is made of the same things that the
atoms are made
the underlying hypothesis is that
there's a single thread
in all the universe that's it and what
this thread is
is it builds atoms
and ropes connected to atoms connected
to ropes connected to atoms connected to
ropes all the way down the line
so it's a single thread in the entire
universe very different than the
particle world the discrete particle
world that quantum mechanics and general
relativity propose
and on which string theory bases its
equations as well
okay uh one of the things you can
explain with this is
the speed of light and here you see it
you see the wave equation
of light light travels always at the
same speed between any two atoms
irrespective of the whether the atom
forms part of a dense
medium or a lighter medium it doesn't
matter between any two atoms the rope
always travels at the same speed
why because if you see there um
in fact i can probably mimic it better
with my rope here okay
uh you see what a couple with my fists
let me remove this for a second here
if uh if you see there uh between my
fists my fists serve as atoms
and what do you see three links maybe
okay so we torque it some more
okay we took it some more and now you're
gonna see more
more um links and each link is shorter
okay so the links have become shorter
meaning the
link length or wavelength if you want to
call it uh has
become shorter and there are more links
there are there's more
frequency okay so uh
this equation i wanna i show here that's
the equation of a rope c equals
frequency times wavelength that is the
equation of a rope
and there i show it in uh pictures uh
if you torque the same amount of rope
you torque it more and more and more
you're gonna
your links are gonna be shorter and
you're gonna have more links
frequency wavelength we're done okay and
here in the prism on the bottom you'll
see that
if you have white light coming from one
area of the uh
and hitting the prism on the other side
you don't have waves coming out or
particles coming out as in mathematical
physics that's a ptolemaic explanation
for
light now what you have is um the
the difference in uh link lengths
for the red color which is longer and
for the blue bluish
side of the spectrum which the links are
shorter and the frequency is higher in
other words there are more links we're
done that's how simple it is
let's take us to the checklist of light
something quantum mechanics cannot
pass light is fast because it consists
of a torsion propagating along a
helical dna-like medium how can quantum
mechanics
justify the speed of light why is it so
fast i mean and why isn't it faster like
why don't those
photon particles why don't they travel
faster why does the wave
travel faster why are they one-way
mechanism see a rope is a two-way
mechanism that's the difference also
there
but aside from that torsion is the
fastest thing you can imagine
so we're talking about a 3d wave here
okay
speed of light c equals frequency times
wavelength we can see why
wavelength and frequency are inversely
proportional
a photon is massless because it is the
mediator
it's it's the thing that interconnects
what we call
mass the atoms okay the electric field
runs perpendicular to the magnetic field
and a top
rope invariably embraces an imaginary
axis as you can see in the
gif below you can see that there's a
imaginary axis now you can see why light
is so
straight or why the goosebumps there
travel rectilinearly along a always in a
straight line why would a
transverse wave not deviate if it's one
way why don't why don't a series of
discrete particles photons travel
straight why would they travel straight
that's that's what you got to explain
there's no reason why don't they just go
in different directions
and light has an angular ternary nature
not because of traveling transverse
waves
but because a rope spinning around its
axis exhibits goose bumps moving along
its structurally wavy surface in other
words a rope is wavy
by nature it's its structure and of
course all
ropes have amplitude okay it's an
attribute of a
two-strand rope okay uh one of the
problems that
uh quantum has it cannot answer is
entanglement okay
and here you see if you have two
particles which are light years apart
100 million miles kilometers whatever
okay
uh one goes clockwise the other one goes
instantaneously counterclockwise they
have no idea how that happens
and it's been so-called confirmed
through an experiment ellen
aspect did it in france uh i think in
the 60s
and he showed that it's a feature of the
quantum world
but what did he show he didn't show that
it's mediated by particles what he
showed is that yeah
effectively you know uh if you uh
check light here the light on the other
end or electron if you're doing it with
electrons the other one over there
uh it goes in the opposite direction and
how do you do that without a mediator
are you going to put angels in their
spirits like quantum mechanics does
is that how we're going to do it under
the rope model it's
it's baby stuff it's kindergarten stuff
uh epr or
entanglement any rope if you look at it
from one end
you could twirl clockwise your friend at
the other end should see it
counterclockwise
and when you reverse the spin of your
angle like you you go from
clockwise to counterclockwise well he
should see it clockwise on the other end
okay
and uh here let me show you what i mean
see if i can do this
okay uh there so
i'm gonna turn mine clockwise hopefully
your end turns counterclockwise okay
you see that now let me turn my end
counter clockwise okay
hopefully your end is moving clockwise
okay so uh yeah um
our rope can explain it without any
problem that's what they've been looking
at all these years the rope models
all features that we've seen
or that we verified uh about light
yeah here's another uh headache for
quantum mechanics it's known as the slit
experiment okay
we send these photons or these electrons
depending on how you do the experiment
and we see these fringes on the wall
when when that goes through
a pair of slits but we're going to do
something else we're going to replace
the slit
with a needle which is the way thomas
young did his second experiment
now the electrum beads or the photon
beads
have nothing to bounce against to
interfere
at the screen okay on the other hand
with a rope model which is what you see
on the right
very simple all atoms are interconnected
before you turn on the light
everything's already connected adam to
atom by two strand ropes
uh twined two strand ropes right uh
they're coiled around each other
and what happens when you turn on the
light all you're doing is increasing
the um the number of links
and each link is shorter now it comes
within visible range
okay the light and what you see is then
standard interference and both
constructive and destructive
interference
according to what we've always done with
waves
nothing's changed the only change here
is that now we know that there is a
physical
entity in that space it's uh the
electromagnetic rope
and once we have this mediator we can
explain very easily why
there are all these interference fringes
we have a physical
interpretation for something that has
driven quantum mechanics just nuts okay
okay uh how about electricity we were
talking a minute ago about electricity
here's the
version from um quantum mechanics
against the rope model
okay according to quantum mechanics what
you have
is the bead going from atom to atom
that's what they
they say but for that you have to tell
me what your atom looks like otherwise
you can't say that that's
what mother nature does there in that
secret world of hers on the other hand
in under the rope model very simple we
have um
all the membranes which are the electron
shells
okay just like in chemistry same thing
but they're merged they're blended into
each other
and they form molecules it's the
blending of
membranes and again i've talked about
that in the past i'm not going to go
over the details here
but they blend and once they blend they
form these long what we call serpentines
the serpentine spins
uh around an axis okay and that's
electricity
and electricity is not negative and
positive mother nature doesn't
understand what negative and positive
and numbers are
she understands physical objects and
here we have a physical object uh
a serpentine we call it and in one end
it's
clockwise the other end is
counterclockwise that's it and you can
do an uh alternate current you can
switch it back and forth between
clockwise and counterclockwise going in
one direction or in the other direction
very simple okay what does that lead to
uh well we
have here a typical circuit the basic
circuit
that you learn in electricity okay and
what do we see well we see that when we
uh close the switch and have a closed
circuit
in the case of quantum mechanics what
you have is all these electron beads
flowing from atom to atom
in the case of the rope model but we
have something else what we have is a
snake
that is coiled around and its uh tail
is touching its head that's what it is
and
when the when the snake twirls it draws
on itself
and what you're seeing is this twirling
there i try to mimic that as best as
possible
what we do we start with the iron atom
we there i'm blending all these iron
atoms
in uh in a wire we're going to assume
the wire is made completely of iron
atoms for simplicity's sake
okay so there's your atom okay and now
we're going to merge it with
those those shells those electron shells
are merged one with the other and we
they form these long chains
okay and now when we close the circuit
these are going to spin
and when they spin that's what we call
electricity electricity
uh is a clockwise counterclockwise
motion of
this wire of this snake that is um
touching it it's it's coiled around from
head to toe and
the signal moves in both directions
simultaneously remember
it doesn't matter uh if you go from tail
to
head or from head to tail uh it just
spins in place okay
so uh very simple very different than
what quantum mechanics proposes
and classical mechanics really for the
for that matter so we're replacing the
electricity that all these people had
for
now 200 years we're replacing it with
with the rope model okay okay how about
gravity which is what
the key issue is here we have gravity
and
we have uh the string theorists they
say that this is a graviton it's just a
closed loop thread
it's a vibrating thread and this
one-dimensional thread somehow
converts into a three-dimensional ball
which is supposed to be this graviton
okay well of course uh people in quantum
mechanics are not very fond of that
uh notion but what do quantum mechanics
what do the people from quantum
mechanics propose
and here you see it uh they they work
with what are known as finite diagrams
okay
and you have here two electrons they're
moving more or less parallel and they
shoot a
photon at each other and you can explain
with this how they push each other away
even if you're going
in time reversal you know from the
future to the present
which is another nonsense that they have
in mathematical physics
now here uh we can explain anyways with
this
model why an electron uh can push
another one away by throwing a photon at
it okay
fine great how do you explain this with
gravitons i mean gravitons has to
explain the opposite thing it has to
explain
with the same model how one electron or
one proton or one atom or whatever
or a rock attracts another rock so if i
have two rocks why would
with certain mass right why would uh why
would a
a rock attract another rock does it
throw gravitons at it if it throws a
graviton on it it's going to push it
away not pull it inwards what you have
to explain is the mechanism
how do you pull with discrete particles
such as gravitons
that's where the problem is and what
quantum mechanics
has not been able to explain it will
never be able to explain
is attraction pull the force of pull
they can explain push very easily
but they're missing half of the forces
in the universe they can't explain how
gluons pull
and they put this bed spring holding the
quarks together
uh that's cheating because when you go
to the standard model you don't find bed
springs what you find is a little ball
and they call it the gluon ball okay
and you find only balls in there so we
don't have a glue on can i explain how
it attracts
physically attracts two quarks together
uh the graviton ball
particle right cannot explain even even
if
if you don't consider the classical one
let's take the quantum one which is a
magical particle
right but even with a magical particle
you can explain the force of pull
because the only way you can do that is
through a casimir effect type
mechanism where you remove whatever's
between them and force it from the
outside push it in
you have to use push pressure you can't
do pull
in a sandbox and that's what quantum
mechanics is a sandbox
they don't see it that way they see it
as a beehive like all the bees buzzing
around
but what they're explaining or what
they're describing really is a sandbox
and you no you can't do you can't
imitate mother nature's universe with a
sandbox with a quantum
sandbox okay okay uh
so what's the uh model that we propose
here it is
very simple all atoms in the universe
are interconnected so action at a
distance is not a
not a problem it's just that there is no
action at a distance we simply cannot
see
or touch the mediator that's what it is
so when i have a little pencil
and i let go of it it falls to the floor
why does it fall to the ceiling and you
say well i don't see anything here i i
can't
touch or see anything between the pencil
and the floor
why did it go to the floor why does it
go to the center of the earth why is it
always converged
upon the center of the earth well
because hopefully
in science or in physics we do
everything with objects we don't do them
with spirits or angels or energy or mass
no we do it with physical object mother
nature works with physical objects we
have to explain why the earth
doesn't fly out of the solar system what
are you going to say that there are
angels that
mediate the attraction between the earth
and the sun while the earth
is moving around the sun in this angular
momentum
trajectory so uh no we there is no magic
every atom is interconnected so if you
see the uh
cube and the cylinder there uh you have
six uh i'm sorry
five atoms in the cube attached to one
atom
in the cylinder they're all on the same
axis okay but as the cylinder approaches
they all go outside the axis and act
independently and the closer you are
according to newton's equation right
distance squared on the bottom mass mass
doesn't squared
the closer you are the stronger the
force
and there you see it you see why because
at different locations
the ropes fan out and you have a
different
weight between another is the weight
of the cylinder with respect to the cube
so
uh uh if you're very far apart like
shown in the
bottom set of three pictures there
you're very far apart all the
ropes converge and act as one like a
single coaxial
and as the cylinder approaches the
cube in space right the ropes begin to
fan out and now the acceleration is
greater and greater and greater until
they're very close by and all the
ropes essentially are completely at
different angles
almost none of them are on the same axis
very simple mechanism there you have the
acceleration of gravity
here i've made a couple gifs that
show this in as a picture here's an
astronaut falling to earth
and you can see what's happening to the
ropes they fan out every atom in his
body which i didn't draw all of them
uh every atom is body is connected to
every atom that comprises the earth now
we can see why there is an acceleration
of gravity
and likewise here we can see why the
earth doesn't run out of the solar
system because every atom of the earth
is connected to every atom that
comprises the sun
and since space is absolutely nothing
under the rope model in other words
we have to define these terms and say
that space is that which has no shape
that's what vacuum is that's what
nothing is that which has no shape
and so no form okay so there's nothing
for the earth to rub its
elbow against space has no friction with
respect to the earth and vice versa
and so uh the uh earth is trolled around
by the sun forever
unless you know uh other there are other
factors like
other planets are pulling on it and so
on but other than that
if these were the only two objects in
the universe the earth would travel
forever
around the sun okay so there you have
the mechanisms
okay and you can see the differences
between what mathematical physics
proposes and what the rope model
proposes
okay uh let's get one more item because
this is what miss uh ms
uh hassenfelder works on she works on
dark matter
she's been uh led to believe that there
is something called dark matter out
there what is dark matter
well dark matter is um is a variable
that was included in an equation
so that the equation matches observation
what did they observe well they observe
something like this they observe
a galaxy twirling around and they say
look the stars on the outside of the
galaxy first of all they don't fly out
they say why don't they fly out i mean
this thing is twirling these uh you know
like when you're in a carousel
and you're hanging on and if it goes
faster and faster and faster hey you're
gonna fly out of there
unless you hold on to something okay if
you're just standing
there and this thing starts rolling
faster and faster you're gonna fly out
of there well why don't the stars do
that
at the edge of a galaxy especially at
the edge of the galaxy
then the other thing is the stars at the
edge of the galaxy you know you would
think they travel slower like pluto
travels much slower than mercury mercury
does
its route in 88 days earth days and
uh pluto takes 248 years
[Laughter]
so pluto is quite slower than mercury
right that's not the case with stars
stars on a periphery
on the edge of a galaxy travel faster or
about as fast or faster than the ones on
the inside how do you explain that
and so what they did was sprinkle
kilograms you know they sprinkled
kilograms here and there
and they say oh we fixed it now now we
know why these things don't fly out
because there's these
dark kilograms and they call them dark
matter and this is what this lady
studies she studies
this inexistent spirit called dark
matter
and she's been they convinced her that
there's dark matter why because there's
no other explanation in their minds
for how this could work if you do not do
it with gravity
and mass in other words you know you
have to sprinkle mass in there
to get the equation to match observation
that's essentially what they're doing
okay and now she's going out to try to
prove the existence of dark matter or
that's already been proven in their
minds what they're trying to do is go to
the lab and say let's confirm that proof
that evidence let's
let's get the evidence right and again
evidence we don't use that in science
evidence is what you use to persuade
people and she never learned that either
she
thinks that science is about getting
proof
running experiments and creating
evidence so that you can convince
someone
including yourself right you want to
certify that what you
believe is true and so you say i'm going
to run an experiment to see if
what my belief if my belief is true
okay um so how do we do it in
real science in real physics well here
you have a galaxy and what we're going
to do we're going to assume that all
atoms are interconnected
that means that all stars are also
interconnected
physically interconnected so we lay our
um
our web our spiders web on top of
the stars and uh so that you can
understand what's happening here we're
putting that
web we're assuming this is a web most of
it is you can't see it
okay or touch it if you could be there
right and
it's because the whole galaxy rotates as
a single
um carousel a single disc okay
and that's why the stars don't fly out
first and second that's why they fly
or travel just as fast as the ones on
the inside or faster there are different
reasons for that i've explained that in
the past but i'm not going to get into
that now
the issue is that if all stars are
interconnected we can explain why
why the stars on the outside travel just
as fast at least
as the ones on the inside okay and
because they're all connected
they're all physically connected to each
other so the whole thing rotates as a
single
um disc as a single carousel
okay and yeah i i didn't show it there
but
we have to include on that the magnetic
field
of the galaxy which is another can of
worms but i'm not going to get into that
today
anyways you can see the differences
between what uh quantum mechanics is
uh hassenfelder proposes because that's
what she's been educated on that's what
she memorized in school
and that's how she got her degree okay
now it turns out that you know they ask
uh well
why can't you see or touch
this rope that you you talk about bill
what are you talking about i don't see
any ropes
you know when when you let go of the pen
do you see anything here
and you might say well there's air here
i don't see it but there's air okay fine
but we can do this in outer space in
fact the astronauts took
a hammer and a feather to the moon for
those who are not flat earthers
okay they took them to the moon and they
let go and then
now there's no air there both of them
felt the same time more or less right
so um so yeah there's nothing here
and so where are these ropes that you're
talking about i mean you're saying these
ropes are physical yeah
and i don't see them i don't touch them
what's the problem
okay listen let's find out what the
problem is with all these people why
they never discovered that and they
never would have because
you know this this is this is where the
problem is this is the uh what they
operate
under they operate under the wrong
definition of the word object
in fact it's even worse than that they
never never defined the word object for
the purposes of physics in fact they
never saw that it was so important to
define the word object
in order to explain give a physical
interpretation
to in physics you know if you look at a
pulley you know you pull
on a rope it goes around a bully and
pulls a box up
all the objects there are you can see
touch you recognize each one of them you
recognize the box you recognize the
pulley
you recognize the rope that's pulling
through you know it's wound around the
pulley that's pulling on the box
and so it's all done with objects
there's no angels there there's no
energy no mass
when you say someone how did you pull
the box box up well i pulled it with a
rope that was wound around a bully and
just pulled the box up
or like i showed uh in the other video
last time
you have felix the cat and he throws a
horseshoe through a window
and it breaks the window so i go and
show this to an audience and say
how did felix break the window how did
the window break
everybody would say the same thing what
i saw is that a horseshoe went through
the window
straight forward that's objective
because everybody
sees the same thing everybody will tell
you the same thing that's how the window
broke
that's known as physics that's known as
objective physics no proof no evidence
no experiment we don't need any of that
we just need
an objective explanation physical
interpretation for how the window broke
and everybody saw the same thing and uh
but the problem here is that these
people are relying on the wrong
definition or an irrational definition
uh of the word object of what a thing is
for the purposes of physics
all these people think that it's a
question of visible and tangible of c
and touch
and never dawned on them that this is
not a question of using the senses
because first you need two objects to do
c and you need two objects to do
touch as you can see there the asteroid
has to touch the earth
okay for there to be touch
okay you need two objects so you can't
use the definition c
touch visible and tangible as a criteria
a criterion or criteria if you're using
both uh to define the word
object that's where the problem starts
okay these people never
define the word object it's the first
word you gotta define in the discipline
known as physics
because you can't do physics without an
object and they never learned this this
is the
golden principle the the
non-negotiable principle of physics you
can't do physics without an object you
need an object you can't do
physics with concepts such as energy or
mass or
charge or field you can't say you you
transferred energy there's no such
monster in physics as
energy or like mr uh feynman said
we don't know what energy is of course
not mr feinman because
energy is not a what energy is a spirit
okay it's a spirit that mathematicians
have used
as a physical object for now over 100
years now
even more than 100 years since the days
of uh
aristotle okay so what is an
object that's what we need to define
first in physics and here we have to
define and here it is
okay object is that which has shape and
first you have to define the golden
principle of physics physics requires an
object you can't do physics without an
object
can you see the air no you cannot see
the air does that mean that air is not a
physical object
yes air is a physical object for the
purposes of physics hair is not an
object in
ordinary speech and people you know have
their ears
torn when i say that but yeah air is a
physical object it's made out of atoms
and hopefully an atom is a physical
object so anything that is made out of
atoms hopefully is also a physical
object the fact that you have all these
loose particles running around you know
doesn't mean it's not
uh physical object does air have shape
yes of course air
does have shape and that's another thing
that people get very confused about
because they say what's the what's the
shape of air
wrong question wrong question
the question is what is the shape of
energy
what is the shape of a tree what is the
shape of a house no the
the question is does it have shape
so you take air in a balloon and the
astronaut takes it out there into space
and he pops the balloon in the middle of
space in the middle of nowhere
and it turns out you color-coded the air
just so you can see it right
and turns out you see a blob come out
once you once you pop the balloon you
see a blob come out
and it's an irregular blob you say what
is the shape of that blob
wrong question does that blob have shape
does it have form the answer is yes
we're done
it's a yes or no type of question not a
what
what is the shape of no it's does it
have shape and the
shape of air here on earth is very
simple it forms a shell around the earth
so it has the shell shape so yes
air does have shape air is a physical
object for the purposes of physics
and you can definitely say that it was
air
that was in motion that blew my house
away some call it a tornado or a
hurricane whatever
it doesn't matter it's air moving air
the object was air that's what we call
that bundle
of atoms okay does it have shape of
course it does
it has a surface that's why it blew your
house away
okay with that we'll see you next time
and bye bye
i'll see you on sunday bye-bye